welcome to the Townsend agency
I run a covert group of exceptional
women
you guys are like lady spies we work
outside the rules you may not know we
exist but we are always watching you are
in the presence of angel hi I'm Naomi
Scott yeah what's that
I'm Kristen Stewart and I'm alibi lenska
and we are interviewing each other today
for our movie Charlie's Angels on
Fandango Fandango all right well right
kids I ran a grande Ariana Grande had a
big role in putting together an epic
soundtrack though we have a favorite
track mm-hmm I do you do I was actually
listening to it this morning
the one with them I need to know the
name of the song I never know the names
of songs and the one with her and
Victoria are in a grand name Victoria
Monet it's big tune that beat is hard
yeah that's that's the tune that I like
you know that which one I mean yes I
need to listen very soundtrack I'm gonna
be alright yeah he just came out babies
did it just come on yeah feels so good
yeah yeah probably say about you you
know yeah and then he's gone that's fire
so enjoy that yeah that sounds cool
sounds great the whole time though yes I
love tattoo I love those guys it's my
favorite fan and I genuinely love that
song and it wasn't like oh my gosh I
love this you know when someone shows
you new music and you have to be like
okay this is great yeah I really not
that you introduced me to that sighs you
know what your film will reveal other
angels for
the world but why are you three better
than all the rest oh oh that's a little
bit aggressive yeah we're not we're not
that's the point of a little thing in
this whole film the point is that we
kind of like laugh and cry and win and
fail and and we need each other yeah
definitely where we have weaknesses of
the other people make us our strengths
exactly yeah so there's an angel on all
of us you know we face adversity there's
nothing we can't overcome yep
together all right
what were your first impressions of each
other when you came together as the trio
of angels for the first time okay how do
we want to do this do you want to well
we should just go one by one who I want
yeah and maybe just in the interest of
time because I know we are all obsessed
with each other yes as a general and
just such a bright energy she was she
was so excited she was so excitable and
you were just lovely you had like a you
have like an innocence about you but
also you know a lot she's very very
intelligent and actually that that was
definitely think and also just like the
tomboy nature of you it was like wow you
are literally like the most learning
standing here but like also like a man's
dream I mean hey let's not limit yeah
and then this one like you know meeting
her was obviously a bit of a thing and
then I could tell she just wanted to it
was the way that she touched us it was
like she broke that barrier very quickly
because she was like hey Chris you're
family you're mine you're mine and I get
you to open up straight away like it's
like you make eye contact with you dude
and it's I'm like I'm here yeah like I'm
you know what it does it takes like one
leg hey dude how are you okay I'm like
hey look diamond gone then creepy what
will my first impression was that I was
so nervous about meeting these guys
and then I was you know I I had like
instant faith that we were gonna be
honest with each other and like maybe I
didn't know exactly who you guys were
yet but I've wanted to and like if we
had to fake being friends this whole
experience would have just been misery I
love you guys
I'd say my thing was I was so happy for
you guys to sort of accept me and you
obviously have the warmest nature ever
like there is I think you said there's a
couple of times there was not a single
bad bone in your body
no she's very pure just purity of heart
hairs or about you and she genuinely
like means it and then UK I mean the I
had literally just said like she just
looked into your eyes and I was like
thank you my fool me with you she was
like yeah I was like thank you so much
don't crush my coffee cup later with
your comments let's do this again so
what do you think of me and um I just do
one is it you or was it me did you just
do I did that was my okay which one of
you would be the best Bosley I think
we're all growing into our bosses Lee's
I'm the oldest I'm gonna take over first
I think you'll take over first but that
was the perfect answer we're growing
into a mess yeah it's true I mean like
our buzz is Liz in the movie and she is
a former angel so there are you know
many many iterations of life life is
long yeah and technically speaking I
would become Bosley first which is rad
yes yeah and you'd be a great boss
Sabeena right with it
Oh world yeah yeah yeah all right
did you so um what's interrupter
Elizabeth banks allow you to bring from
your own life or own personality that
you used in the film I think I was able
to bring my athletic ability
full-stop definitely yeah the cool thing
is we all play sort of versions of
ourselves
none of our characters are huge
departures I think she chose all of us
because it would be the most fun to
watch people have genuine experiences
and kind of like highlight what we
already kind of brought to the table
especially in my case she kind of like
real women real real emotions yeah like
all right especially in your case
because in my conception of the idea
she's funny like Christina's is a funny
individual ya know it was really fun
like uh again like when your friends
really see you you're able to be
comfortable and like you know do stupid
stuff that feels like you could only do
it on your friends and yeah that never
happens in a movie because everyone's
watching and so in this case I was like
just wanted to hang out and be a
goofball
and you know I think they see what
Kristen said and but I don't know but
her intentions are so universally adored
and she wants to use her talent and her
intelligence to make the world a better
place
and like not that I mean that that's
that makes me sound very self-righteous
no not I mean I just said that she
doesn't have a bad bone in her body the
character is a reflection of that yeah
there's definitely that element and even
though she's American and she's a genius
it's you're right there is this
something there there's an essence there
I think there is and I'd never seen it
actually one thing that's similar I'd
never seen a gun before Elaine had never
seen a gun before
so that was kind of fun / scary alright
who's it next yes okay what is your
earliest memory of going to the movies
Oh fun yeah I know me and I my memory of
mine pretty much for a lot of my
childhood I don't remember it I don't
know which came first but I remember my
two earliest movie theater memories are
[Music]
Jurassic Park with my brother who is
four and a half years older than me and
started crying like me and we had to
leave because he was like really scared
and I was like dragged out of this movie
theater like No so I'm gonna go off that
and you've just reminded me of what my
actual first thing was what I want to
remember Peter Pan yeah you which one
okay the one that we were younger than
five action one yeah yeah it's a pizza
pan there's a scene where the teddy bear
gets his head like sliced off I wept
I really wet I mean guttural cried at
the death of this teddy bear I well I
don't know because I loved hook that was
my wife and love I adore that movie so
much but not in the movie hardly seems
but doesn't not that movie but I also
read that in one of those big books that
could just be taken like making up I
love that I love I remembered which I do
think actually was when I'm a bit older
which again adds to the whole like I
don't have a good memory was the gram
was the Grinch I do remember going to
watch that and just like loving it and
feeling all Christmassy this is too long
I also saw way too young
Something About Mary and I was like why
is her hair sticking I don't get it
Cameron Diaz man oh my god she's hot
she's the coolest lady moving on with
her beautiful egg stunning
Kilis okay you all get to wear some
really great disguises in the film have
you ever had to wear a wild disguise
this is I mean probably for you so that
you weren't recognized in public
that's definitely I was always afraid
that like somebody was gonna be like
that there's her just looking insane
always look so cool she means like if
she dressed up
maybe laser sword dressed up as a
plumber yeah oh my god so funny that you
say that because that would be my
disguise if I were to choose one if we
had two people if we'd like infiltrate a
building or something I'd be like what's
up guys just here to check the pipes
jumpsuit picture I want a big oversized
wrench that I can lay against my
shoulder and be like don't mind me
fellas I'm just here to check the pipes
you've never been into Scotland you've
never had so you just go like but you've
never honestly if you try and hide
yourself people just look at you more
and they're like who's trying to not
yeah yeah I think the only time I've
ever like I'm really tired and just like
I just can't really talk to other humans
right now I'll put a hood on it I'll put
my hair and for my face and it'll be
like dude if you come UPS me right now
like you're really just setting this
also when approaching figures literally
if you just go no please please and they
get really uncomfortable and that's
great I'm usually totally willing it
thing is do you do that one Hollywood
Boulevard in your blend right I think
maybe I just if I just go out as me
people kind of don't think it's me
because they're like they look how tall
I am NOT like surely not so yeah well I
that it might get tougher for you
because you are you know you stick out
in that way yeah I don't have that oh
yeah here we go the Angels have a fun
Batman debate in the film we're putting
you on the spot yeah who do you think is
the best bat
Oh Robert Pattinson yet to find out I
think honestly him and zoe kravitz yes
go get to play literally she already is
coming yeah no I can't wait I cannot
wait to see that I've known those guys
for a long time obviously
yeah no I but other than that yeah I'm
trying to think I mean for me like
Michael Keaton is definitely the one but
then they're all pretty cool I think
thirty good is pretty great yeah yeah
yeah that's very serious I didn't grow
up with that so less for me that's all
that's like wow that's really cool but
are you serious it's really fun to watch
Michael Keaton yes can we do your Rob be
like I'm Batman
I think we've fortunately for you run
out of time my name is Ella balance goth
I'm Kristen Stewart and I'm Naomi Scots
thank you for joining us
you